bien ici votre art groc nationale je
sors de captain marvel et je pense que
nous avons pas mal de choses à nous dire
je fais d'ailleurs une petite dédicace
trains coûte aussi tu passes par là je
ne vous cache pas que je ne m'attendais
pas spécialement un gros film je ne
m'attendais même presque à rien de
spécial et j'ai été assez surpris et
j'ai quand même bien aimé le film
on va bien évidemment rentrer dans le
vif du sujet je vais spoil donc vous
êtes prévenus pour passer très vite fait
sur le film
carole est un personnage qui est assez
attachants on s'y fait très vite c'est
un peu une sorte de kwilu au féminin
elle est assez drôle etc bref c'est que
du positif ce personnage on s'y attache
très vite ça fait du bien de revoir
coulson et unique fiori jeunes est
pareil tout aussi attachant et c'est
très marrant de le voir sous une autre
facette moins sérieuse que dans avengers
et on comprend même les débuts du alors
ce besoin de justifier les origines les
débuts en général d'une saga ça se fait
de plus en plus ça on le voit dans star
wars notamment ça m'a pas choqué y ait
certaines choses dont on savait que
c'était le chat qu'elle est griffé son
oeil mais voilà ça ne m'a pas
spécialement trouble et j'ai trouvé tout
était assez bien amené et a c'est même
surprenant donc c'est plutôt cool
effectivement les crises ont donc
finalement les méchants pour parler
assez simplement et au final les skrulls
j'avais complètement oublié déjà alors
j'ai vu le film il ya trente minutes
soit au final des êtres le gentil donc
des différences avec le les comics donc
comme quoi le mca ne se base que sur
l'univers et j'espère que certains s'en
rappelleront et s'en souviendront parce
que des fois certains se réfère trop
comics bien il est inutile de se voiler
la face
captain marvel et over tchité mais
puissance mille et pour les plus vieux
abonnés d'entre vous ça doit vous faire
très drôle
naîtrait rire parce que justement
j'avais fait un trois théories sur
doctor strange où je disais je m'affole
est en mode mais docteur strange
il est trop haut pays les troupes
puissant il fait de la magie etc
il remonte le temps il va il va défoncer
anoci la même humilié loki vos côtés
c'est de la pisse de chat c'est même de
la piste de ce mercato ou de sperme et
de ce mercato
je crois que c'est seulement bref trêve
de plaisanterie donc origin story assez
classique un accident a lieu et elle
obtient ses superpouvoirs et elle va
découvrir son personnage au fil du temps
tout au long du film
donc ces pouvoirs sont tirés de
l'énergie photons mais ça me perturbe le
nom photons car pour moi c'est vraiment
laid pouvoir tirer du chant quantique
comme il avait été supposé et comme on
le voit plutôt dans le film car les
pouvoirs qu'elle détient possède à peu
près les mêmes codes cinématographiques
dans antoine par exemple quand ils sont
dans le champ quantique
par exemple avec havas qui est égoïste
qui était l'ennemi d'antenne 2 donc le
paradoxe avec photons et cantiques
j'arrive pas bien à saisir la différence
et j'ai l'impression que ce serait
plutôt la même chose peut-être un terme
utilisé dans les années 90 l'énergie
photons peut-être après je me connais
pas je suis vraiment nul
et là c'est une réaction vraiment à
chaud je vous préviens donc y aurait
peut-être une certaine différence
néanmoins est-ce que ça va apporter
je ne sais pas trop voilà parce que ce
n'est pas la dimension quantique en
elle-même comme je les supposés plein de
fois et que peut-être captain marvel
pouvait peut-être se servir d'eux
duchamp quantique l'annoncé seulement
les pouvoirs et du coup c'est le terme
photons qu'à utiliser donc ça ça me
perturbe un petit peu mais bref
donc on va faire directement le
rapprochement avec endgame suite à la
scène post générique le bipper de nick
fiori a été appelée a été retrouvée par
natacha steve war machine et banner est
exposée avec un signal du coup le signal
de captain marvel qui dure depuis un bon
moment
cette période et pendant le fait qu'ils
les énoncés et voit les personnes qui
ont disparu au total donc ce sont les
partis du trailer où nous les voyons
faire le compte des gens disparus et ses
terrasses et la même période
s'ils sont allés chercher le bipper
auparavant soit soit c'est a été coupée
au montage pour le film c'est parce que
ça et c'était peut-être pas une scène
très intéressante soit ça veut dire
qu'il ya eu des événements passés dont
le fait qu'ils aient retrouvé le bipper
mais nous sommes quand même globalement
dans le début du film et du coup carole
semble arriver à ces dans le début du
film
le problème que j'avais captain marvel
dès le début en fait c'est que infinity
ward et endgame sont un peu un film en
deux parties
infiniti voir la première partie
évidemment eden games qui clôture la fin
le problème c'est qu'entre ces deux
films il y a eu deux films marvel il ya
eu entre man 2 entre man et la guêpe et
du cou captain marvel qui vient de
sortir
le problème de ces deux films c'est
qu'ils n'apportent rien au nc eu
globalement ils n'apportent rien à part
juste des réponses pour avengers quête
il s'est rebaptisé avengers 4 et c'est
ça qui me dérangeait beaucoup et au fait
que je ne m'attendais à rien concernant
le film de captain marvel
parce que clairement entre man et la
guêpe n'est pas un film qui sert
vraiment dans le mc eu à part pour
amener le champ quantique et
le fait que où étaient entre man dans
infinity ward et comment va-t-il
apparaître dans une game donc bien les
vortex temporel et en même temps ça
amène le champ quantique la carole
denver ce c'est vraiment la même chose
le film sert à introduire le personnage
de captain marvel qui est une clé pour
avengers 4 une clé scénaristique et en
même temps il ya le principe de pouvoir
quantique photons c'est pour ça que j'ai
du mal un peu à faire à voir les
différences mais je sens qu'il ya
vraiment un rapprochement entre les deux
termes
donc techniquement nous avons nos
réponses qui nous sont proposés par le
marvel eux-mêmes captain marvel et ant
man donc le vortex temporel chant
quantique et carole denver ce sont
vraiment les trois choses principales
qui sont mis en avant pour un game pour
un petit peu nous aiguiller puisque les
deux reviendront dans endgame entre man
et carole denters je sais pas si vous
avez bien me suivre pendant donc
clairement j'ai été très surpris de
quelque chose c'est la puissance de
captain marvel
là c'est clair on entre dans la phase 4
endgame est vraiment le dernier pas de
la phase iii mais aussi le premier pas
de la phase 4
la puissance de carole denver est
totalement démesurée et c'est une vidéo
que je pensais vous faire un jour mais
le paradoxe avec natacha ou accueil et
là par exemple captain marvel ya
clairement un gouffre énorme entre les
deux personnages et je sais pas comment
ils vont faire évoluer la chose on
pouvait prendre l'exemple de red skull
par exemple red skull qui était à la
base seulement soldats allemands pour
pas me faire démonétisé avec le crâne
rouge etc qui aujourd'hui a été maudit
par les pierres et gardiens de la pierre
de l'âme il a aujourd'hui connaissance
des pierres le personnage a évolué en
crau ils ont fait évoluer le personnage
et ils vont peut-être leur utilisé pour
les futurs films
c'est peut-être ce qu'ils vont faire
avec d'autres personnages comme par
exemple antoine qui va rester assez
longtemps dans le champ quantique et
la mère de la guêpe est resté 28 ans
dans le champ quantique je crois ou 20
ans je sais plus mais elle en a obtenu
des pouvoirs grâce à ça des pouvoirs
avec de l'énergie quantique
elle est une pile d'énergie quantique un
petit peu comme carol bond elle c'est
plus sain un réacteur nucléaire une
bombe atomique
mais du coup en dessous man pourrait
aussi avoir des pouvoirs et évoluer
techniquement et peut-être qu'il
pourrait faire ça avec natacha etc
mais bref l'annoncé garantie peut on
change de sujet cependant il ya un gros
problème à carole denver ok elle est
surpuissante
ok elle est très rapide vraiment elle
est invincible
clairement elle est invincible je vois
pas comment thanos peut la battre
justement dans in game thanos ou est ce
qu'il est personne ne sait dans les
trailer on voit vite fait à nous levitt
fait se reposer sur sa planète etc mais
thanos et caché il est à l'abri des
regards il est à l'abri de tout on ne le
retrouvera pas pourtant thanos sera dans
avengers endgame peut-être pour déjouer
le plan des avengers qui serait de
peut-être retourner dans le passé je ne
sais pas je ne préfère pas m'avancer
vous avez déjà mes vidéos théorie sur
tous ces sujets mais thanos est
introuvable
et justement le trailer les deux trailer
accentue le fait qu' on peut pas
retrouver thanos juste le retrouver lui
casser la gueule à réparer le gant ou
récupérer le grand et les pierres et hop
machine arrière etc
et puis c'est bon non ça c'est
impossible et le problème c'est que
carole denver ce est symbolisée
clairement par la puissance alors à part
si elle nous a caché certains pouvoirs
encore inconnue aux spectateurs j'arrive
pas à bien décelé encore l'utilité de
carole denver a par botter le cul thanos
qui est absent alors peut-être elle
maîtrise le champ quantique etc
c'est une supposition que je me suis
fait pendant le film car la zone où elle
parle à l'intelligence suprême
l'intelligence artificielle suprême j'ai
un petit peu l'impression que c'est une
sorte de d'autres dimensions un peu
comme le chant quantique
même si ça se passe à l'air de se passer
dans sa tête et ses terrasses affecte
beaucoup c'est comme si elle était dans
une autre dimension en fait avec les
murs qui se change etc
il n'y a pas vraiment de matière c'est
très étrange
peut-être je me goure totalement c'est
fort possible mais il est possible qu'il
ya un rapport là dessus également il ya
un gros problème et ça je n'arrive pas à
mettre le point dessus donc captain
marvel est vraiment montré comme étant
ultra rapide 1 elle peut se balader dans
l'espace comme sa tête découverte sans
problème mais où est elle passée pendant
du coût 20 ans 30 ans environ
et ça c'est quelque chose de vraiment
qui me bloque je sais qu'elle retourne
sur la planète décrit pour remettre de
l'ordre etc et continuer à sauver des
skrulls
mais le problème c'est que elle a
retrouvé sa meilleure amie avec sa
petite fille
enfin la petite fille de sa meilleure
amie elle a retrouvé sa famille les gens
qu'elle est mais elle sait qu'elle est
humaine
elle a conscience qu'elle a vécu sur
terre et sait où était-elle pendant tout
ce temps en fait je sais qu'elle menait
la guerre mais pendant tout ce temps
sans jamais revenir sur la terre une
fois de temps en temps aux autres parce
que du coup s'il revient sur la terre
elle a forcément dû entendre parler des
avengers entendent parler de certaines
guerres etc
elle est quelque chose que je n'arrive
pas vraiment à ulissi a élucidé
également vous êtes beaucoup à me le
demander et j'en avais parlé vite fait
une fois je pensais le plus détaillé en
vidéo mais je me suis dit que ça allait
pas forcément vous intéresser mais au
final c'est une question qui revient
assez souvent assez souvent pardon ou et
captain marvel dans infinity voir fin
pourquoi elle n'a jamais été appelé
avant infiniti voire plus tôt et bien la
réponse est assez simple techniquement
un petit peu tiré par les cheveux mais
tout de même assez assez simple et
franchement c'est une explication qui me
convient assez qui est assez
philosophique nick fury ne possède pas
un pilier dans le mc eu mais en possède
deux le premier pilier est évidemment
carole denver ce alias captain marvel le
premier héros qu'il a rencontré le
premier avenger est également la plus
puissante
cependant captain marvel a d'autres
choses à faire et c est pendant tout ce
temps
nick fury s'est fait un deuxième pilier
et c'est tony stark qui est il me semble
le deuxième avengers qui l'a rencontrée
je sais plus si nul que ça se passe
avant ou après iron man le tout premier
bref et du coup en fait
iron man il faut savoir qui n'est qu'il
n'est jamais tombé au combat
nick fury iron man c'est le seul
personnage à qui il se confie il se
confirme même pas iron man mais à tony
stark
c'est le seul personnage avec qui il
parle avec qui il se confie comme dans
avengers 2 par exemple
age of filtrons et le problème c'est que
dans infinity ward tony est totalement
absent tony est bloqué sur titan et ne
donne plus aucun signe de vie et c'est
la première fois que ça arrive tony ne
peut être que considéré comme mort et
c'est justement la raison pour laquelle
nick fury décide enfin d'appeler captain
marvel c'est que si tony tombent au
combat si tony tombe c'est qu'il n'y a
vraiment plus aucun espoir est que là il
faut vraiment faire appel à captain
marvel grossièrement c'est ça la raison
j'ai pas grand chose à dire de plus
techniquement le film m'a vraiment
beaucoup plus j'ai aimé les petits côtés
un petit peu féministe de temps en temps
enfin le fait de dénoncer certaines
choses en rapport avec les femmes et en
même temps c'était l'époque donc c'est
cool qui met en avant également le chat
le chat et le mercan je sais plus des
jeunes on est vraiment un petit truc en
plus qui est cool et ça encourage je
pense les jeunes à aimer les animaux etc
appréciez les animaux à s'occuper d'eux
comme nick fury le fait est que ça peut
inspirer certains enfin bref c'est il ya
eu quand même de beaux messages dans le
film je pense que je n'ai pas dit mon
dernier mot on reviendra sur ce film
et justement je préfère vous teese est
maintenant le 29 mars
je vous conseille d'être là enfin bref
on reparlera captain marvel très
prochainement je pense que d'ici demain
ou après demain j'ai peut-être quelques
théories en tête
a vous de me dire dans les commentaires
un dit moi dans les commentaires si vous
voulez des théories sur captain marvel
alex était argot rock n'hésitez pas à
laisser votre plus gros pouce bleus
activer la cloche vous abonner me suivre
sur twitter que le lay honneur soit avec
vous
[Musique]